- [Voiceover] This is Sal
here, and I'm with Kim Kutz,
who is Khan Academy's American
History Content Fellow,
and what I'm curious about is...
In school, you learn about the Civil War,
you learn about slavery, that slavery was
a cause of the Civil War,
but at least for myself,
I never got a full context of what were
all the dynamics that
led to the Civil War?
Was it just something
that happened overnight?
- [Kim] Oh, defnitely not.
You know, I think the
seeds of the Civil War
were really with the United
States at its creation.
I think there's sort of
an essential contradiction
in the United States as it's born.
We're this country where
all men are created equal,
except that most of
the states in the South
have slavery, where people are clearly
not created equal, so they couldn't win
the Revolutionary War without
including those states
and kind of giving them what they wanted
in retaining slavery,
but it means that the US
is born with both free
states and slave states,
and they're gonna continue
to try to figure out
how to balance those for
the rest of the 1800s.
- [Sal] We have this map here.
This map is a later
period, but it shows...
This is actually closer to the Civil War,
but if we even look at
the original 13 colonies,
you can see which ones were free states
and which ones were slave states,
and then you obviously
have these other states
that come in later,
which we'll talk about.
What you're saying is, at
the founding of the country,
this was already an issue.
There were people in the
North who weren't fans
of slavery, and people
knew that at some point
this would be irreconcilable,
or maybe they hoped
that it would be a (laughs)
reconcilable difference.
They said, "No, we gotta
unify against Great Britain."
- [Kim] Exactly.
- [Sal] So they said,
"Let's just become a country and do it."
- [Kim] You know, even Thomas Jefferson,
the author of the
Declaration of Independence,
he knew that slavery was a contradiction.
He called the issue of having slavery
"like holding a wolf by the ears."
You can't hold onto it,
but you can't let it go
because so many of the wealthy elites
who were going to end up in Congress
in the South are slaveowners--
- [Sal] Including himself.
- [Kim] Exactly,
so they wanna protect their interests.
- [Sal] So, the issue
is there from the moment
that the country is
founded, and then we get
into the 1800s, which
is really the run-up.
The Civil War doesn't start
until we get into 1860
or shortly thereafter, or actually, 1860.
What's the big picture
that really leads up to it?
- [Kim] Well, I think
what we're looking at
when we get into the issues
that lead to the Civil War,
it's really about how the US
handles getting new territory.
- [Sal] And the US was getting
a lot of new territory.
We have a map here.
I guess the first really big chunk is
you have the Louisiana Purchase in 1803,
and so you get all of...
Let me shade it in.
You get roughly all of
this stuff right over here,
so that's new areas that settlers can go,
and it becomes officially
a part of the US,
and what else happens?
- [Kim] So, as we get
these new territories,
out of them you're gonna get new states,
and when new states come into the Union,
they're going to come
in as either free states
or slave states, so we've
balanced the interests
of the North and South
up until this point,
from the Revolutionary
War, so that there's
equal representation in Congress
between free states and slave states.
- [Sal] Well, why does someone care?
If I'm someone in Massachusetts,
why do I care whether
the new state of Missouri
is going to be a free
state or a slave state?
- [Kim] Well, I think
there are two reasons
why you might care.
First, if you're an abolitionist,
and these are the people
who we know very well,
like Frederick Douglass,
or William Lloyd Garrison,
who was the editor of the
newspaper The Liberator.
These are the people who feel that,
correctly, slavery is morally wrong.
Slavery is a corruption
of the essential principles
on which the country was founded.
It's something that destroys
lives, destroys families,
but another reason if
you're, say, in Massachusetts
or Pennsylvania, why
you might care whether
a new state is a slave
state, is you're worried
about opportunities for
yourself out in the West.
We know that Horace Greeley,
this famous newspaper editor, he says,
"What do you do if you're
a young man in New York,
a young white man, who doesn't
know how to get ahead?"
He says, "Go West, young man.
"You can go out there,
you can get some land,
"you can start a farm,
but if you go out there
"and you find that all of
the land has been bought up
"by rich slaveholders from the South,
"you might not be able to get any land,
"and you certainly might not be able to,
"for example, sell your
corn at a rate low enough
"that you could beat
somebody who has free labor."
- [Sal] So, a lot of times
there's a lot of focus
on the moral argument, which
is a very strong argument,
but there's also this
interesting economic argument
which you just talked about,
which is it's hard to
compete with slavery.
I mean, you're literally
talking about labor
that does not need traditional wages.
- [Kim] Right.
- [Sal] That is literally
slave labor, and so if you were having
your own farm and you don't own slaves,
how are you going to compete with that?
So, that was the reason for
some folks in the North,
an economic argument.
Now, would these people be
considered abolitionists?
- [Kim] No, the way that
we think about those,
we call them "anti-slavery."
So, anti-slavery
advocates, they don't think
that they can get rid
of slavery in the South.
Even if they don't like
slavery in the South,
they don't even see how
it would be possible
to get rid of it, but they do
think that as these new states
are coming into the Union,
they could prevent them
from becoming slave states,
so that it's possible
for the Western lands to remain free.
Abraham Lincoln, I think,
is a really good poster child for this.
I think we'll talk about
him a little bit more later,
but Lincoln is born in Kentucky,
one of these new, Western states.
His father is a small, white farmer,
and slaveowners move into Kentucky.
Later it becomes a slave state,
and his father can't find work,
his father can't find land, so he ends up
first having to move to Indiana,
then moving to Illinois,
so this is literally a case
of one of these poor,
white farmers who just
can't compete with slavery,
which is one reason
why Lincoln himself is
later gonna come out
so strongly in favor of making sure
there's no slavery in the West.
- [Sal] So, abolitionists:
slavery is amoral,
it needs to be removed from,
definitely the United States,
possibly the world.
- [Kim] Yeah, absolutely.
- [Sal] Anti-slavery: they
also think slavery is bad,
they don't like it, but they think it's,
"Well, but I'm not gonna
fight that fight to remove it.
"Maybe that's hard to do, or impossible,
"but it shouldn't spread.
"It's not fair.
"It's the reason my dad wasn't able
"to be able to run his farm."
- [Kim] Absolutely.
- [Sal] So, you have
the Louisiana Purchase,
and in other videos we
talk about that famously
Napoleon sold it for quite cheap,
because frankly, he couldn't defend it
(Kim laughs)
because he was fighting
these wars in Europe.
That's the first chunk of land,
so you have all of these states,
and they need to figure out whether
they're slave states or free states,
but why would...
I mean, I talked about why
would a Northerner care
whether a slave or a free state.
Why would a Southerner care?
If I'm a slaveowner, I own a plantation
in South Carolina or
Georgia, why do I care
if Missouri is a slave
state or a free state?
- [Kim] Well I think, just as their
political interests
are tied up in slavery,
all of their money is tied up in slavery.
In 1860, the most valuable thing
that anyone owns in the
United States is slaves.
You can't compete with that kind of money,
so they wanna make sure
that if a new state comes
into the Union, that
state isn't a free state
because then the free states might have
more representation in Congress,
and then they can vote to outlaw slavery.
So, if your whole fortune
is built on slavery,
if you're a white
slaveowner, they outlaw that,
then you're left with nothing.
- [Sal] I see, so the North,
there's the moral argument,
there's the economic argument,
slavery is hard to compete with,
and in the South, "Hey,
if we have too many
"of these free states, at
some point they're gonna have
"enough of a voting
power in the government
"to maybe abolish slavery one day,"
which would completely undermine,
if I'm a slaveowner,
my economics of my reality.
- [Kim] Right, and they are
sort of essentially amoral.
Even someone like Jefferson who knows
that slavery is wrong, his whole wealth,
his whole fortune, his
whole political dynasty
is built on the fortune of owning slaves.
- [Sal] You know, one of the first points
where this really gets
balanced, this issue,
is we have the Louisiana Purchase in 1803,
then starting to carve out
the Louisiana Purchase,
you have states like Missouri.
They get to their critical mass of people,
of population, so that
they can become a state,
and so what was the Missouri Compromise
all about in 1820?
- [Kim] So, the Missouri Compromise
is when we have enough
people living in Missouri.
These are white people, generally,
who have come from the Eastern states,
and they apply for statehood.
You've got an equal number of slave states
and free states already in Congress,
so if Missouri comes in and
they wanna be a slave state,
they're going to upset the apple cart.
They're gonna upset the balance,
so there will be more representatives
for the South than
there will be for North,
and everything they've done so far
has been predicated on
this tenuous balance
between free states and slave states.
So, they debate this
in Congress for months,
and eventually what they do is say,
"All right, well, we can't decide,
"so what we're going to do is admit
"the state of Maine at the same time."
- [Sal] And Maine, the territory of Maine
was already part of the United States.
How was it not already a state?
- [Kim] It was part of Massachusetts,
but as you can see, it's
really only tenuously
connected to Massachusetts, so they divide
this territory up so that it can have
its own representation
in Congress, so they say,
"All right, well, we
can't solve this problem
"of the balance of power
between free states
"and slave states right
now, so what we're gonna do
"is just kind of extend our balance.
"We're gonna keep this compromise going
"to make sure that there
are the same number
"of free and slave states,
so we'll let Missouri in
"as a slave state at the same time
"we let Maine in as a free state."
- [Sal] Fascinating.
I see where this is
going, that you have these
very tenuous compromises while more
and more territories are being added.
It's exciting to see
where all of this goes.